good morning guys welcome back to the
farm in today's video we're going to be
up potting some of these beautiful
cherry tomatoes well snacking Tomatoes I
call them snacking Tomatoes anyway we're
going to be up potting some of these
cherry tomatoes and I'm going to give
you three tips that's going to make your
Tomatoes double in size in less than a
week just stick
around
[Music]
you
welcome back guys the variety that we're
working with today is called Mountain
magic and I call them snacking Tomatoes
simply because they are actually bigger
than your average uh cherry tomato now
we grow Sun Golds we grow uh super sweet
100s and we grow black cherry um cherry
tomatoes here on our farm and we grow a
mountain magic now this tomato here will
get almost the size of a golf ball it's
smaller than your regular slicing tomato
but it's bigger than your average cherry
tomato and this variety is very popular
at the markets that we attend and we
tried to grow this several um secession
plants throughout the year to make sure
we got it on hand throughout all of our
markets and these Tomatoes just like
every tomato that we grow we start them
in smaller trays so we can start more of
them number wise and then we up poot
them to a bigger container um so they
can actually get a better root base
before we put them in the ground and
they no really script on how we start
our Tomatoes it just depends on what
trades we've got on hand at the time
this is a 50 Cale flat and this is
basically a strawberry flat it's all it
is and we started these guys in this
because I had 100 seeds and that equal
two trays now we do start a lot of our
seeds in 512s and you can see this we
have to be real careful with this tray
here because it'll dry out really fast
if you're not careful and the they will
get root bound also if you're not
careful so you have to pay real close
attention to these guys and you know up
poot them when you think that they are
ready but yeah these guys here are about
a week away from needing to be up potted
some of them have their true leaves on
them but a lot of them are still in the
calan stage and you can see there a lot
of tomatoes in there I think I got five
or six of these trays that I've got to
up poot here in the next week or two so
I'm going to go through and I'm going to
show you the process that I use to up
poot all of our Tomatoes not just
cherries determinates indeterminates
heirlooms all of our tomatoes are up
potted the same way and we generally up
poot all of our tomatoes is now to get
away from having the up pot you need to
start it in a bigger container and we
don't simply for the reason that we
don't have the room to do that we don't
have the room to store a lot of these um
at one time like I said in any given
time there's 3 or 4,000 tomato plants
sitting around here all the time there's
3,000 in my germination chamber and
there's another 2,000 down here at the
back of this High tunnel sitting on the
ground so we don't have a lot of room to
do that so that's why we start them in
smaller
trays so that brings me to tip number
one give yourself plenty of room to grow
your transplants out if you can't get
around to putting them in the ground at
the time that you think you will then
they need to be able to stay in whatever
you're up potting them in now I like to
use these glue cups because they're
cheap one and two that I can reuse them
every year simply just wash them out
stack them up and put them on the shelf
and next year I can do the same thing
now this works for Peppers this works
for a plant this works for just about
everything that you want to upot there's
no real I mean I get to use these or
I've got a lot of these trays here these
little 2-in cups sitting around and you
know just something to hold soil more
than what is sitting in now that's
really all you're looking for so the
whole purpose of this video is to show
you how we up poot these small tomato
plants and you can see I've got one that
I pulled up
these these small tomato plants that
look like this that were grown in these
trays and make them look like
this that was grown in the same tray it
just hadn't been up potted yet and you
know we could leave these guys in here
and they would get to this size here and
we could transplant them straight out
into the Gard but that's not you
generally how we do things these guys
here are going in this High tunnel and
we will be transplanting these out here
really soon probably here in the next
two two or 3 days but these guys will
have to actually sit out for a while
before we can put them in the other high
tunnel that we're working on now so tip
number one give yourself enough room to
have a cushion in order that you don't
get in a bind and have to up poot them
again give them enough room that they
can grow in here and these plants
they'll get that tall inside of this
container here a foot or more and you
know you'll still be in good shape
because you got a lot more soil in here
and you can actually fertilize these
guys while they're in this
cup all right so the second tip I'm
going to give you is that we are going
to use the same growing medium that we
started Ed these tomatoes in this is the
same soil it's sterile there's no
amendments or anything whatsoever in
this soil we're actually going to take
two scoops of this and we're going to
put in a 5 gallon
bucket and there's no real accurate
measurement to this but I take two of
those Scoops and you can see and I take
a 4 oz scoop of garden
tone and you guys know I swear by Garden
tone and if you don't know what Garden
tone is I'll put a picture of it over
here so you can see it you can get it
track Supply you get at Lowe's you get
at Walmart sometimes but I'm going to
take a 4 o scoop a level scoop and I'm
going to put in that bucket with those
two scoops of soil and then I'm going to
just take my hands I'm going to work
that in and mix it up really good and
what this is is our pre-plant fertilizer
and if you followed our Channel enough
you know that I preached that you need
to put down pre-plant fertilizer when
you can for plants that are heavy
feeders like tomatoes like cabbage like
cyers all these good vegetables they
need a pre- plant fertilizer something
that is not already available in your
garden give these guys what they need to
get a good start so now we have our
mended our up poot mixture which is the
same mixture it was started in it set
for it didn't have any mims in it our
seed starting uh media is sterile guys
we don't use any kind of mimt any kind
of fertilizer in our seed starting media
and be careful what you're hearing out
there different videos I'm hearing a lot
of guys that's telling people to
actually Mi fertilizer in their seed
start media and you need to be careful
with that you know there's a lot of good
Farmers out there there's a lot of guys
that have some good content on YouTube
but be careful what you're watching out
there because there's a lot of stuff out
there that can get you in a bind if
you're not careful my advice to you is
use a sterile seed starting mix and I
use Black Gold I get M attractor Supply
it's omry listed I mean it's organic um
most Pete Moss is organic but basically
it
is sterile and this is what it looks
like made by Sun gold that's it that's
what I use and you can see it's arm
listed so it's organic we can use it
here on our phone no amendments no
fertilizers no nothing we put it in
there each plant each seed has enough
energy to get itself to its first set of
true leaves period just naturally it can
do that once it gets to this
stage is when you need to give it
something to feed
on
that's what we did in this bucket so the
recap give your plant something big
enough to get a good root base in and
use a pre-plant fertilizer when you up
poot them not at planting the seed when
you up poot it and now we're going to
talk about the last step which is to
feed your plants once they're
established now whenever you upot a
tomato plant pepper plant whatever
you're going to have some level of
transplant shot that means that plant is
just basically going to stall and it's
going to establish itself get its roots
going back in the you know into the soil
trying to run out and find its place in
there to basically get established
before it starts growing again now um
you know all plants do it some do it
less than others it just depends on the
conditions but once your plant is
established and you can tell that it's
out of that shock stage you can start
feeding it with a either a balanced
fertilizer or in our case in tomatoes we
want to put on some folage and get the
stocks of this plant a little thicker so
once we plant it you don't see them just
drooping over like this they come flimsy
they look leggy we want plants that are
rigid see I can wiggle this thing and
see how rigid that plant is that's what
I like I like tomato plants that have a
backbone to them and to do that before
you get blooms on your plant what you
want to use is a higher nitrogen
fertilizer and in our case since we do
plant or fertilize organically we use a
Chilean nitrate which is what is in this
bag here it's a
152 it is omry listed it is organic you
see right here but it is a natural form
of nitrogen that your plant can utilize
immediately it doesn't have to wait for
the soil to break it down your plants
can use this now and what we do is
basically give our tomato plants a bath
in this stuff we set it in those totes
out there what I use is a a tablespoon
and a half that scoop right there and
five 5 gallons of water don't overdo it
so once these plants are young like they
are we take these things and we spoon
feed them to get them to look like this
so to start with we're going to take
this plant and we're going to water it
nothing in the water just water plain
well water we're going to water this
plant and let it get established once we
can tell that this plant is actually
trying it's trying to grow then that's
when we're going to utilize
the nitrogen the organic nitrogen that's
when we're going to utilize this stuff
here in our totes and bottom water these
guys and these plants will explode they
will literally double in size in a week
I promise you all right guys so I got to
get busy but check back in with us later
this week we're going to be up potting
these guys here all of the heirloom
tomatoes that we started in trays a
couple of weeks ago and if you missed
that video I'll put a link to it up here
and if you found anything useful
anything entertaining or just plain old
interested click this subscribe button
over here in this right hand corner and
as always guys we appreciate you
stopping by thank you for your support
and we'll see you in the next one